c'est toi qui était à l'endroit où je
suis
plus personne Kuda est sorti quand et il
n'y a aucune place pour l'amitié
salut
en battant sur des terrains vagues
j'étais comme toi avant
[Musique]
le mentor est son petit protégé
tu peux m'expliquer tête de jeu
[Musique]
vous avez des enfants une fille qui a
ton âge comment tu t'es fait ça
[Musique]
la chambre est payée jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine
fais attention à toi
tu as l'air d'avoir pas beaucoup dormi
c'est une gamine paumé je lui ai pris un
hôtel je vais filer du fric et hier à la
disparu je crois pas que tu puisses
faire quoi que ce soit
c'est bien la fille de quelqu'un
ce mec est complètement barré je peux
pas abandonner ici elle a 15 ans est-ce
que tout va bien
il rapporte beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
je suis venu pour te sauver
j'ai rien à voir avec tout ça et moi je
crois que tu as tout avoir avec ça